hey everybody it's Mike from orderflows
and welcome back to my channel in
today's video I'm going to talk about
one of the new tools on the orderflows
trader 7 software called the retail suck
and I know what you're thinking you're
thinking yeah retail Trader suck no no
no the reason why it's called retail
suck is because um it's based on the
order flow it's looking for areas where
um retail Traders are potentially
getting sucked into losing positions in
a way getting uh fooled into being
trapped in the market um through no uh
means by themselves and it does show up
in the order flow I mean you know the
order flow is very robust you can see a
lot of things taking place you know
between um you know the retail Traders
the institutional Traders um you know
market makers alos Etc and the tool I
talk about is the retail suck tool so
let me just bring it out here for you so
you're going to go into the indicator
settings you're going to find it here
under the RS uh here retail suck we'll
just enable it the default colors our
chartreuse whiches this like uh sharp
green colar and medium Orchid we have
the uh opacity set at 35 and for now
I'll keep the swing filter disabled just
to show you how it looks we're going to
draw it out until tested so anytime um
on the chart that there's a potential
retail suck taking place it's going to
highlight it if it's bullish it's going
to be green if it's bearish it's going
to be this medium Orchid
color
and here we go so let me get the
crosshairs going up here right you can
see a bearish one here a bullish one
here a be a bullish one there bullish
bullish it's a nice bearish bearish A
little bullish one there um bullish
bullish now again there are different
ways you can use this right this is just
a tool which highlights something
happening in the order flow by
itself probably not going to want to use
it as a
standalone indicator just like saying oh
anytime there's an instance of a retail
stock going going get long or get short
you could but I I don't think that's the
best way to use it um there's a couple
ways I'll talk about using it one is
okay when you see it obviously coming in
here um you know areas to look to get
long and get short if you can combine it
with other forms of
uh order flow or technical analysis I
think that's going to help you um a lot
in your trading
so one of the ways that I always tell
people is put it in context okay if
you're going to look for areas where
Traders are getting sucked into bad
positions in a sense getting trapped in
the market where's the best opportunity
going to be for you to capitalize it on
it well at reversal points okay and
where do reversal points come in well
they're going to come in at swing highs
and swing lows so what we're going to do
is we're going to enable the swing
filter which is this little button here
you just click it to get the check mark
there and it's linked to the swing
period up here of five okay you could
adjust that to whatever if you want a
bigger period you can set it to 20 50
whatever um then you're just going to
click apply but I'll keep it at five
which is the default that I have it set
at okay so now you're going to see it's
coming in at the swing low if there's
any here or a swing High okay so that's
going to make it a bit more effective
for you because now you're not just
taking it willy-nilly anywhere there's
you know um signs of a retail suck
coming in based off the order flow okay
so you're you're sort of filtering it
down you're refining it okay now another
way to refine it is if you want to use
the swing filter
okay again you know there's one here
let's just go back here this is with the
swing filter so you see with the swing
filter right you get a lot fewer signals
okay
now what I also like to use with the
retail suck is the prominent points of
controls okay so turn that one on turn
that one on one two and three Prominent
Point control 1 2 and three click apply
so now what I'm going to look for is
when there is a retail suck here and a
bullish Prominent Point of control here
okay there's one there um let's go
through here see where the other ones
come in this one doesn't have a
Prominent Point of control so I would
pass on that
trade this one does just went sideways
as a retail suck in bearish P point of
control okay just went sideways could
live with that
um
this one's got a bullish Prim point of
control with the retail
suck okay and this one it's the retail
stock but with no bearish Prominent
Point of control okay
so and plus one other thing to note that
is with the look back filter enabled
okay remember on the retail stock I had
the look back filter
uh where is it here enabled if I disable
it okay now it's going to find me a few
more
instances of the retail
suck but I also have the prent point
controls on so I'm going to look for
those times where there's that
Confluence where you have the bullish PR
point of control with bullish retail
suck or bearish PR point of control with
bearish retail
suck um here's one right here this was a
nice trade there's one right here this
was a nice trade as well obviously that
was the one from
before um let's go
back right here this is a nice one nice
move right
here again that's that one that just
went sideways on
you this one's just the retail stock
with no uh Prominent Point of control
these are retail stocks here 1 two three
but no Prominent Point of control no
Prominent Point of control on these
two none on this
one none here none
here here's nice retail suck with your
bullish Prim point of control and you
got that nice move
up another one right here bullish one
this bearish retail stock had no
Prominent Point of control
again no Prominent Point of control no
Prominent Point of
control this one had a Prominent Point
of
control right and Retail suck with
bearish Prominent Point of control
so you know there's so many tools
available in the orderflow trader
there's like
30 one tools 32 tools um you you can
combine them to find out you know on
which you know what Market you're
trading on what time frame what works
best on that market right it's not about
uh trying to curve fit because you know
this is crude oil right this is a eight
range chart and you know if I were to
change this to you know gold eight range
chart right I'd be looking at the exact
same things I'd be looking for the
Prominent Point of control with the
retail stock right here right there's
none this is just the retail stck here
no bearish prent point of control
control right that's the retail suck no
bearish Prominent Point of
control here we go retail suck with
bearish prent point of control there's a
bullish one here okay didn't work
out we had a bearish one
here okay just looking for these
instances here's a bearish one it's a
nice bullish one
here and here was a bearish one didn't
really work much here was a bullish one
here me you had a bullish one here and
you had another one came in later here
but really should have been long from
here
[Music]
um you know like nice bearish one right
here for this move down so again you
know
it's think of the orderflows trader
7 as a Swiss army knife so to speak
right of waterflow tools right and you
could mix and match these you could use
them
alone you could combine them you know
you want to use sequencing or you know
ratios or with a gap or you know open
point of controls um you know the
there's so many different tools on here
that really you can create your
own orderflow trading plan based off
different aspects of the orderflow and
then you just wait for those instances
where they all come
together and then you lean on it right
now does that mean every time you know a
bearish p control retail stck comes in
is going to be a winning trade no of
course not but it can happen often
enough that if that's all you're trading
that's all you're looking for right you
know your expectancy then yeah that
those are the trades you can lean on
when they appear in the market all right
so I hope you guys enjoy this video and
you know it starts to get the the wheels
in your brain turning on on how you can
use uh the orderflows trader software to
help you in your trading all right
everyone so I'll see you guys on the
next video bye
bye